on this international women's day we
take the opportunity to honor female
accomplishments but we also pause to
consider the struggles and universal
challenges that women face globally
one of those struggles is of course
gender-based violence women face this
every day both on and offline digital
violence can include things like cyber
stalking hate speech and the
non-consensual use of photos and videos
which of course has lasting consequences
on women and girls our next guest frames
this as a human rights abuse issue dr
natalia connem is executive director of
the united nations population fund an
agency that's dedicated to sexual and
reproductive health rights for women and
girls dr and welcome to quick take we're
going to dive into how your agency is
helping on the issue of digital violence
but we'd be remiss if we didn't start
with asking you about what's going on
with women and girls as they flee
ukraine
women and children being separated from
the men who are being kept to fight what
is your single biggest concern right now
for the women and girls who are fleeing
the impact of conflict on women and
girls is heartbreaking and it is really
dangerous and i'm preoccupied by the
understanding that at this very moment
the majority of people fleeing out of
harm's way are women and they're
children and they're vulnerable they
need protection
by the way
it's important also to understand that
within the next three months
about 80 000 ukrainian women who are
pregnant will be giving birth and during
those three months they need their
health care they need protection and
they need to be able to deliver safely
while giving life
we also see
pictures and videos of women giving
birth in abandoned subway stations in
kiev at the moment as well so there are
women who are staying behind in ukraine
what are ngos like the u.n agency that
you work for doing to ensure their
safety especially when you can't or your
monitors can't always be physically
present all the
time me highlight that the united
nations as an organization of
multilaterals
not governmental but working with all
governments has played a really
important role
in doing two things secretary general
antonio guterres has called for peace
for ceasefire for an immediate
succession of the hostilities which are
the reason that women and girls are on
the run and i'm talking to the tune of
two million people who have left ukraine
in such a short space of time
the second thing that multilateral
organizations such as unfpa which is the
sexual and reproductive health agency
hence our concern for pregnant women for
violence which shadows women when they
are fleeing and i'm i'm speaking of
gender-based violence up to and
including rape and these concerns of
trafficking that can occur in these uh
crises
however when it comes to assuring you
know it's winter food is an issue the un
is working in concert on issues of
transport and again insisting on the
fundamentals of peace dialogue as a way
to resolve issues
yeah we've seen a lot of video footage
of children uh fleeing on their own
without any appearance of parents in
sight dr connum what can be done to keep
those children safe specifically girls
who are crossing on their own and and
may not have any form of parental uh
guidance or or assistance with them to
kind of keep them safe how can they be
kept safe then
again i insist on full respect for women
and their concerns and you know this uh
concern for children which unicef also
expresses is an understanding that they
are vulnerable when people are
vulnerable and need protection
everything has to organize in order to
defend their human rights let me tell
you that setting up shelters for people
in crisis right now is so important
during uh
the weather conditions that people are
facing moreover there's the matter of
biology
unfpa provides dignity kits which are
handed out by the midwives by the social
workers by the numerous nurses and
doctors that we employ to shield people
from having biological concerns like
menstruation
um the dignity
contains health
hygiene
uh contents that are very much
appreciated during this time
the other one uh the other point i
really have to make is that the welcome
on the other side of the border is also
something that we're helping with yeah
the neighboring countries uh
also need assistance as they receive the
refugee population
well when we think about gender-based
violence of course digital violence
comes to mind as well and i know that
you and your organization have a big
campaign around that can you tell me a
little bit about what you're doing to
allow women to have agency and control
over their bodies and kind of copyright
their own bodies online that's right
well
it has to be understood that the virtual
space now
is an arena where violence happens and
it is real it is just as real
without borders or limits as something
that happens in the physical space and
often these things spill over and the
question that unfpa is asking in our
body right campaign which we invite
everyone to join
is why should a copyright for a poem or
a book or a song have more weight
than the image of a woman or girl in the
virtual space you're the owner of your
body wherever you are the b with the
circle around it akin to the c for
copyright
means that objectionable images that a
woman or a girl did not consent to
should come down and were asking tech
companies to please understand that
these are human rights violations the
other very important thing is that
bullying online intimidates women and
girls who have every right to
participate in that space so that's what
bodywrite is trying to say loud and
clear my body is my own i'm the owner of
my body right
how much of the burden then falls on the
big tech companies the social media
companies that are in charge of these
platforms when it comes to addressing
this versus
individual bad actors who will find a
way to do this with or without the help
of those platforms
you know this is a great question
because what unfpa is saying
is that there's a system that has to
acknowledge in particular a gender
differential
that makes women and girls vulnerable at
a time when a lot has gone online
because of the pandemic
girls are
learning online hence the type of
intimidation the name calling the types
of insults but also threats and stalking
it's a system that has to respond and
tech companies the power of business the
understanding of regulating that
environment has to privilege women and
girls being safe online
and also to take down images that are up
there without consent
really really important because it has
huge
mental health implications depression
all the way through suicide when people
are attacked relentlessly online and for
women politicians also to be respected
in the virtual space right and women and
girls are of course punished if their
images are posted online without their
consent so it's just a very vicious
cycle dr khanna when we talk about this
and i think about the future of the
internet and i think about the metaverse
i'm more and more concerned about having
another new space to navigate where
we're going to continue to see some of
the bad behavior we've already seen
online follow us into the metaverse what
is your number one biggest concern as we
start to develop spaces and go into
spaces in the metaverse specifically for
women and girls
working assiduously with unfpa in over
150 locations around the world the
bottom line is full respect and full
dignity for women today is international
women's day it's a time for us to look
at each other and to say yes we value
women's participation across the whole
arena and the metaverse indeed the
universe should be a gender equal space
women are highly capable of
uh functioning of leading of running
their business being a teacher whatever
it is that she wants to do
she should not be hampered by the type
of
violence that can occur online and it's
a very intimate type of violence it's a
very intimate type of offense when she
opens her phone
she should not be harassed so ultimately
i believe that we need allies business
is a great ally
men and boys are great allies in
understanding that the online space is
now contiguous with quote unquote real
life so very important to claim your
body right and this is what the website
on bodywrite that unfpa has launched is
saying so please join the movement we
need action on this point
really important reminders on all that
dr condom thank you so much for joining
us that was dr natalia connam executive
director of unfpa speaking with us on
international women's day about this
really important issue